let's uh let's let's segue over to this
next story which uh victory may be a a
um
contributing factor in an upcoming civil
war here in these united states
from timcats.com idaho passes bill
banning abortions after six weeks idaho
senate bill 1309 is modeled for similar
texas legislation passed last year
the bill now goes to governor bradley to
be signed into law little has supported
similar abortion bans but has not yet
offered public comment on this bill the
abortion bill does include exceptions
for circumstances such as rape incest
and medical emergencies the current
abortion laws in idaho authorize
abortions until the fetus is viable
outside the womb typically around 24
weeks if the governor signs the bill the
new idaho abortion ban could take effect
as early as april so we're seeing
similar laws uh they mentioned over at
timkest
mississippi there's there's texas and
they say at least 12 states have
introduced bills model after the texas
abortion ban the texas law senate bill 8
empowers private citizens to sue anyone
who helps facilitate an abortion after
the legal limit
this is a big story because six weeks i
think is in terms of what we've seen
across the country the shortest amount
of time so far i believe right because
like 11 weeks was mississippi and they
got sued over that now at six weeks
a lot of people even people on the left
believe that roe v wade will be
overturned come what june so this is
just another in another you know uh shot
across the bow maybe it's not even right
to put i mean this is another law
leftists abortion activists are going to
go after this absolutely but it may be
meaningless if come june
they issue a issue a ruling overturning
roe v wade
well and of course they will not be able
to stand the fact that unborn children
are not being murdered in your state
even if that continues to be legal in
their state
well i think there's sort of a defensive
mechanism here as far as i think one of
the big issues in our country is when
people move from california or new york
to texas
because because of texas success it
actually leads to failure um and so by
doing something like this it's actually
not even about abortion what it's saying
is those people in in seattle and
washington state and oregon right over
the the state line i believe of idaho
who are moving into idaho it's saying
stay out and it's necessary to do that
because otherwise idaho will become uh
portland in however many decades well
very interesting i i hear what you're
saying but think about the implication
there
do you believe that there are um
women
who are
scared that if they go to idaho they
won't be able to get abortions like
it's just kind of a crazy thought to me
that there's a woman who's like but what
if i get pregnant and i can't terminate
the pregnancy in the state you know what
i mean
so you're suggesting if a woman wanted
an abortion and she was in an i she was
an idaho resident she would just cross
the state line to get it well not
necessarily what i mean is like the
implication is effectively if this is
true that this bill is a warning to
these people the only reason they'd be
scared is because they plan on having an
abortion no because they're obsessed
with virtue signaling i mean look at all
the boycotts they do of florida and
texas for all kinds of bills that really
won't affect almost anyone it's just a
symbolic gesture that this isn't you're
not going to fit in here it's amazing
how they lie too like we i can't get
over the florida uh parental rights bill
which i keep lying about constantly well
and with this i'm not sure why they
decided to do it i want to just ascribe
the best possible motivation to them and
say they're really trying to save unborn
children and really god bless them for
doing this but i do think it could have
this very interesting side effect you
bring up if you're left-wing people
being willing to move to these states
but that said on the other hand you're
mentioning virtue signaling here
and an important part of that concept is
it's completely hollow and meaningless
so i think there could be reason to
believe that these left wingers still
might end up moving to these places just
because all they know how to do is
engage in hollow symbolic virtue
signaling and their actions never map
onto this yeah so the things they say
they want so we you know i i deal with
this when we we've been looking at
property in west virginia more so in the
past year but now that we have the new
property
hasn't really come up but one of the
issues is
we hear a lot from locals that there
will be maybe a pig farm or a shooting
range and then these dc people who are
trying to escape the cities over covet
and other problems that they create move
out here
when they go to buy the property they're
told now you have to sign these
documents saying you acknowledge a
shooting range and a pig farm nearby and
it's going to stink and be loud and they
go oh yeah of course
but what happens then when 10 more
people move in all around the pig farm
and shooting range now there's more of
them than you and they say okay we did
agree to that but now we're gonna have a
vote oh look at that we've all voted to
get rid of your property and now you're
gone yep so that's one of the things we
see so i'm not entirely convinced the
leftists will be like oh no we better
stay out they're gonna be they're gonna
move in and go wait i can't do what and
then eventually enough move in and they
say vote get rid of it you know what i
mean yeah i get what you're saying
though about it it's sort of a prelude
to a civil war or some sort of national
separation is the 50 states uh
just in increasingly uh
states going far left and far right and
so there's a differentiation within the
country even if nominally we're still
one um because people are very mobile
now especially after coronavirus a lot
of people working from home i think
we're going to see people
self-segregating politically absolutely
yeah yeah so so that was the point i was
bringing up initially is that um
i think abortion could be a great moral
cause
for the left or the right which could be
you know on par with slavery of course
the left will probably scream at me for
saying something like that like what or
maybe they'll agree no they'll agree
because they say it is literal slavery
for a woman to not be able to murder her
unborn child right i've heard that it's
like the moral issue may be on par with
that denying a woman her right they
could say what what did george carlin
call it being a brood mayor for the
state
if that's if that's the left's
perspective on you know bearing a child
when they decide not to or they don't
want to then they probably would agree
it's a great moral cause on par with
slavery but if that's the case and
you've got there's no there's literally
no middle ground there's zero there's
zero middle ground it's just there's no
so how do you how do you resolve
something like that
if they overturn roe v wade i think
you're gonna see a bunch of states to
start banning it and then i wonder you
know will you see leftists setting up
makeshift underground the underground
abortion clinic railroad or things like
that for sure
you think so oh yeah abortion since the
dawn of humanity has been part of us
species i can't imagine stop it ever
stopping
i was so i'm sure that some people will
still attempt to have abortions but i
believe that it will be greatly
decreasing in number in the places where
it's illegal but i think what tim's
asking is not necessarily will there be
people who break this law but our left
winger is going to try to set up an
entire underground infrastructure to
continue abortion to get a girl out of
the state without people knowing yeah
i would imagine yeah because if you
think about if you think about it
if someone lives in a state that allows
it and they don't want to get one they
don't do anything they just say i'm not
gonna get one
uh but so another reason why i do
genuinely believe that abortion bans
work
is because i mean this was a while ago
and i can't remember the exact state but
planned parenthood tweeted something out
i i don't think it was the um the texas
law because that was too recent but they
basically tweeted a frowny face about
how in certain areas where abortion was
more difficult to access the birth rate
had increased i have to find this
it's actually ridiculous um i'll see if
i'll see if i can pull this up but i
mean people also the a the law is a
teacher and b if abortion bans didn't
decrease the prevalence of abortion the
left wouldn't be upset by them
that's a good point and one that's very
relevant because i think that they're
afraid of actually changing the thinking
about abortion and about things like
parenthood and i think that very much
goes back to feminism and telling women
that they have to get rid of this
unwanted child if it unfortunately
happens to them we don't know how this
happens but you know children happen and
you have to get rid of them somehow and
they just fall flat because they're like
well if you wanted to stay at home and
be a mother you would just have a kid
and you couldn't abort them and then you
could be a worker and i think that also
gets back to communism but that's very
strong and i think there's a sort of a
pattern emerging of the democrats
becoming the party that hates children
with closing down schools for two years
because of their deference to the
teachers union which is a vicious and
ruthless thing to do i mean children
kill themselves because of that children
are going to be illiterate irreparable
harm was done um you see the things like
uh you know covering up the rape and
loud and you see things like in florida
where they want to groom your kids at
the age of uh
you know kindergarten uh into being you
know transsexual or whatever um this is
almost
another thing is the er and this is
important coming back to the migratory
patterns that we're seeing with
coronavirus
democrats love urbanizing areas if they
can build dense buildings
that is how their real way of taking
over an area you want to have more if
you have more than an acre you're going
to be conservative if you have less than
an acre you're probably going to be
liberal
wasn't that a big thing that uh you know
they wanted to uh urbanize the suburbs
absolutely they want to get rid of and
joe biden this was part of his platform
to ban single-family zoning and so they
think we should all live in cities and
take trains or buses everywhere and that
is an anti-child policy too because as
anyone who has children knows you're not
going to go to the store and lug home
four gallons of milk and you know costco
size you know whatever all the stuff
that we all do as parents it's
impossible to do
uh in this urban lifestyle um and
democrats are obsessed they want you to
live in a high-rise they don't want you
to have land um it is uh really
anti-there's a number of ways that the
democrats are anti-family beyond
abortion i think when you get out of
cities and actually experience
having land and space you'd never want
to go back dude the cities were another
reality before the internet in the 90s
late 90s to early 2000s it was the only
way to go to get involved with anything
bigger than farm town usa so i went to
new york city 2001. want to be an actor
now you don't need any of that online is
the city that's where everyone gets
together power goes out
your immediate community is key if the
power went out then maybe we'd start to
form i think maybe cities was like a
stepping stone of our evolution towards
but that's if the power stays on if the
electricity goes out
then it's hard to keep waiting for
starlink man
we're getting we're getting uh uh solar
upgrades we're you know we're waiting on
um starlink
so once we have starlink it's like you
got
i hear it's not that good you know you
know initial test runs were you know 100
megabits or something but now i'm
hearing that once everyone starts using
it it drops down to maybe like 10 or so
but it's it's like um lower latency
which means you can game and do stuff
this means people could be working out
of montana dude you know so it really
allows people to kind of spread out and
i think one of the biggest problems is
population density in cities makes
people go insane no freedom do you work
on a boat with starlink you could live
on a boat in the ocean i wonder if that
explains some of the irrational behavior
the high strung nature of some of these
uh
you know hyper online uh leftist
journalists and things like that just
the mental stress of living in a city oh
dude i mean when i when i worked at uh
fusion my apartment in brooklyn
was two grand per month and it was they
called it a two bedroom because the
living room in the kitchen were one room
and then the living room was a bedroom
so it was a two-bedroom it was a
one-bedroom but that's how they do it i
know a bunch of journalists who lived in
railroad apartments you ever see a
railroad apartment in new york city a
railroad apart railroad apartment is one
long room with doors every third of the
way so you have a bedroom with a door in
the front in the back and your roommates
walk through your room to get to their
room oh wow it is amazing it is a
bizarre dynamic where they're all
lecturing or looking down on everyone in
the middle of the country and the people
in the middle of the country are just
laughing at them like dude i'm sitting
on my deck looking at mountains looking
at a you know i had some urbanists
lecturing me and i was like i'm looking
out my window and i i see a fox taking a
nap in my apple orchard which was true i
had 40 40 fruit trees and a fox was
taking a nap and their only report was
you're lying
so they just they can't comprehend that
people actually do live this way and it
doesn't necessarily require more money
or anything it's just
our way of living is better than there
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there